vanessa is already uh not in the in the
zoom call
like okay let's go he's better than the
magnus man
oh i'm better than magnus who is he i
don't know let's go
uh pawn okay
we did we did
we did on
no increments with it night night
by the way somebody just knocked my door
pawn
can i just quickly go and check up who
is that no pawn
okay fine but it could be something
really important it can be
can be many if it's no if it's your
thought it cannot be man
what do you mean
uh next three moves you play bishop
knight and king
okay
[Music]
it's fine he'll be back he'll bet
he'll be back i mean uh vanessa don't
worry
he's a very unusual guy this happens to
him it's okay it's okay
it's fine don't uh turn off the the
video on the
pawn and bishop one and bishop it's okay
but he's a good guy overall so it's okay
bishop you sink
bishop
[Music]
hello raja can you hear me did he didn't
make a move how can i make bishop
i uh oh okay move but
and then i was just wondering if you can
hear me anymore bishop
why bishop man this is theory
trust me why not you have to trust the
brain trust the brain right why not
the brain trust the brain raja okay
famous game of of knowing
i don't know but it was some very famous
game where you go queen c1 and then rook
c4 rookie four you know
very famous game after queen takes f6
yeah queen queen f6 knight d5 queen b2
knight c7 rook d8 queen c1
yes yes okay this i know but still i
didn't know this was polygamy's game but
i remember night
night night yes okay
okay
okay let's read the chat wolfpack
podcast
on
queen vanessa is already in the chat
quinn yes okay
yeah we go for me treasure yeah yeah i
know you settle for small things
i know your stuff in every stream you
know which we have done together
there's always one question saying what
is raja drinking
always tea as usual what's the problem
there's always one question i said it's
about at night
night oh yeah
let's go there very bad move
oh no raja no knight b3 what i know it's
a very bad move the one i made knight b3
because d4 was possible
so what do you do now oh god yeah
okay now what is it it's still winning
now
you play knight
queen yes but uh knight b3 was winning
on the spot
yeah um
okay look rook
i mean i don't know okay
it's good as well um it's a tea in the
champagne glass
yeah any transparent glass makes it fine
i mean it's okay
but no it's not champagne champagne
raja queen queen queen champion later
move first champagne after we win this
super matches
no champagne oh did it by the way how is
your how is your schedule now
what is it like very very very very
sofia packed yeah very packed
on
yeah that's crazy somehow yeah
do you have time for chess
not much probably not really
sadly sadly not i mean i want to have
but it's likely not one
porn guys we need the mukesh ambani
sponsorship for video so that he can
call
it send him the letter
we can do it together the petition
petition to save a grand master
from the um from the
financial incentives
what the word incentive do you know it
yes yes i know
so can we do the move please because 20
raja bishop bishop bishop i said bishop
10 times
and now next move okay
you have to go on your own go on your
own f3 flip play play just play anything
you don't have time my internet i don't
know if you can even hear me
gg okay oh raja showing some speed
nice speed yeah haha good speed good
speed
good speed yeah nice feels good yeah